what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting back into our
discussions on Earth X I'm really
excited about this because this is when
we start to wind things down for the
most part where we have like need to do
one more video left after this and
that's pretty much when we conclude it
but this is cool because this this
actually has a pretty huge moment at the
end of the story the cool thing is again
we're basically talking about a story
where everybody on earth came
superpowers you know it's essentially a
story where black bolt of the Inhumans
had detonated the Terrigen bomb and
effectively set the Terrigen mists all
around the earth waking up all these
different powers of terrigenesis inside
of people and the result is that the
where we would normally believe that
like the earth might become a better
place what this basically gave us was
the idea that the earth became somewhat
of a worse place because you had people
who were like well now I've got
superpowers I can do anything and this
really hit at home with the idea of the
skull basically this young kid whose
power was to dominate the minds of
others now of course Captain America
having become somewhat disillusioned as
well as Peter Parker who abandon his
role as spider-man them alongside
whatever superheroes are left that
haven't been dominated by the skull are
basically trying to like keep New York
from completely going under and that's
one thing to bear in mind the skull was
based out of LA and so over the course
of however long he had basically
transitioned from Los Angeles moved all
the way east to New York now this is a
pretty big moment because what this
means is that essentially anybody with
superpowers that the skull came across
was brought under his control and when
he moved into the city of New York
basically he's got an army of millions
of people at his disposal the guide
dominates the entirety of New York he's
got everybody he picked up from LA which
is already in the millions moving all
the way to the east so I mean it's a
huge number at this point and in truth
we're talking about Captain America for
the most part fighting a losing battle
but the cool thing about this is that
when Peter Parker shows back up again
and when he starts to talk about how
these guys are basically mindless slaves
of the skull suddenly it triggers
something in the mind of Captain America
sudden we hadn't thought about before
and what we end up doing is
transitioning to the residence of Ben
Grimm the thing and Alicia masters and
this is cool because remember Alicia's
powers basically is the ability to give
life to clay to essentially mold
something out of clay and then bring it
to life so that it can either you know
operate of its own accord or it can do
whatever she tells it to do but Before
we jump into all this what we end up
doing is picking back up with really
like like the Celestials themselves at
last video we had talked about how
blackbolt of the Inhumans had basically
left earth and taken off to the moon to
confront the Celestials for when they
arrived and try to find a way to destroy
them but what we're basically told here
in this conversation between who watch
you The Watcher in Reed Richards is that
in truth the actions of Black Bolt are
our null I mean there's there's nothing
he can do to stop the Celestials he's
just not that powerful he doesn't have
the capabilities to do it but recounted
and says that was never the point the
point of Black Bolt was never to like
destroy the Celestials the point of
Black Bolt was to let out a quasi sonic
scream that would basically be an SOS
and it would call for help he would
basically send out a signal to you know
one or more people more beings out there
that would bring them in and essentially
allow them to fight on behalf of Earth's
superheroes to stop the celestial host
and so what we end up doing is jumping
back to Captain America and this is when
we find out the entire plan that he had
the goal was that if those individuals
who can think for themselves are
basically taken under the control of the
skull then basically you know
essentially make an army of people that
the skull can't control and that's where
the whole scheme comes in Captain
America's idea here is to create an
entire army of play figures who can
fight against the skull and his army and
the skull can't control them but this is
cool because what is up happening is
Captain America shows up as a clay model
only for us to realize it's not actually
a clay model it's Captain America
covered in clay the idea was to get
close enough to the sculpt that he would
never suspect him that he would just
think it's one of the soldiers who were
out there but when Captain America runs
up on the sculpt he does the only thing
he can do and he kills him now that's
huge this is a huge moment with Captain
America Captain America under normal
circumstances will never kill an enemy
it's kind of a wool of his character as
far as I'm aware in Marvel Comics I
don't think he's ever actually killed
people before I mean I'm sure there's
times where like he would have to but I
mean for the most part like no enemy is
beyond redemption he's very much you
know Batman esque in that regard in
terms of how he views enemies and how he
views you know foes and different things
like that but in this instance and this
story this is designed to be a Captain
America's starkly different from the one
that we're used to a Captain America
that is kind of beyond the role of
saying like everyone can be saved and
looking at like the harsh reality of the
war of the world he's in a saying
sometimes there's only one alternative
and that is to kill the skull it's the
only option they had and so with the
skull being killed everybody's basically
released from his mind control and then
essentially we end up finding
that like Tony Stark where he's been
residing in this Citadel of sorts but
he's basically aware of what's going on
with the Celestials that these celestial
beings essentially are the reason why
everybody has powers or at least why
some people have powers and that
blackbolt was essentially kind of like
trying to complete this circle without
really realizing what was going on and
the reason why I say this is because
blackbolt of the Inhumans was aware of
the Celestials he was aware of the idea
that the various superheroes on earth
didn't just get powers one day that
their genes had been modified by the
Celestials so that they would gain
powers somewhere along the line and that
they would basically be antibodies to
protect the celestial seed inside of the
earth so that when as he matures and
when the seed is ready to basically
emerge from Earth that yes it would
destroy the entirety of the planet Earth
but a new celestial would be born
blackbolt knew about all this and
blackbolt had given everybody on earth
powers by the you know by way of
terrigenesis because he knew that the
Celestials would eventually return one
day and when they do that would have to
be superheroes who would be capable of
taking down the Celestials the problem
is that no one has the power to be able
to do this because remember when it
comes to terrigenesis it's a crapshoot
there's no way to know what powers
you're gonna have there's no way to know
what your powers are going to be it's
just you go into care Genesis and you
emerge with whatever abilities you have
but this random chance the probability
of somebody developing powers that you
know can basically challenge the
Celestials increases exponentially the
more people there are with powers on
earth and so at the same time Tony Stark
had realized exactly what was going on
as well and what Tony had been doing the
entire time he'd been hiding out in his
bunker is basically developing a massive
god-killer kind of armor now again this
is one of the reasons why Earth X is
such an influential story because you
look at things like this and then
suddenly you jump forward to the more
recent run of Iron Man when when you
know they're introduced to like the god
killer armor which is basically a giant
suit that was designed to destroy
Celestials and so again that's why this
really influenced a lot of Future
stories but it's funny because even Tony
Stark himself realizes that he's a
stopgap measure he doesn't have the
power to like destroy Celestials he
doesn't have that kind of ability
because the Celestials are godly beings
they're entities they're designed to be
beyond any real human that exists out
there the other half of this is that
picking up with like the Asgardians
themselves the funny thing is that loki
is the only person who realized the
nature of things now remember we
discovered this earlier in the story who
wants you The Watcher he basically
explained this to us earlier
story that the Asgardians aren't beings
who are literally gods they were
formless they were just some sort of you
know some entities that existed out
there and they were given form when they
first met humans that humans looked upon
them and said Wow
these beings must be the ass Guardians
like if this must be Odin this must be
Loki this must be Thor and then suddenly
these beams adopted that mentality and
they became the very heroes of the very
characters that humans believed in and
so literally the Asgardians are funneled
by human belief that's the whole basis
behind Ragnarok that Ragnarok won't
happen because like Loki will lead an
army against Asgard Ragnarok will happen
and Asgard will end because eventually
humanity will be destroyed and when
humanity is destroyed there'll be no one
left to believe in the Asgardians
ergo these beings will revert back to
their shapeless forms quote unquote
Asgard will come to an end but Loki is
the only one to have realized this Odin
for all these people none of them
believe him they all think it's just the
ravings of a madman that is insanity
and so Loki does the only thing he can
do and basically kills himself and
reverts to the realm of mistress death
now we're gonna find out there's
actually a motivation for why he did
this but it is cool because again it's
people who kind of look at him and say
well he's a trickster you know he's a
God of lies is all he is
and he's just making things up it's just
absolute nonsense but jumping back over
to Iron Man you know in this kind of
last-ditch effort to take down these
Celestials to buy as much time as
possible he literally just like flies
his vessel into one of them and it's
totally destroyed but what is up
happening is we basically find out that
like the efforts of Reed Richards and
really the efforts of Black Bolt rang
out true that where black folks voice
was sent out into the cosmos in an
effort to find help that we switch over
to like Jameson basically the son of Jay
jonah Jameson a person is working on the
moon at the moment that he's essentially
gained access to the ultimate nullifier
and where he intends to use the ultimate
nullifier to destroy all things there's
no need for him to and the reason why
there is no need for him to is because
the backup the signal sent out by Black
Bolt has been received the being that
they were hoping for who would show up
to basically save earth has arrived what
this means is that Galactus has finally
returned back to earth but with that
being said guys we're gonna bring this
video to an end if you are new here to
comment explain and make sure you guys
have the sub button to become part of
the robb cork if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and yeah
in the next video we wrap it all up we
are ending Earth X something else that
I'm also gonna do to you and a lot of
you guys have noticed this recently with
a trend it's been going on when we
like a multi-part story you guys have
noticed like we've created one big video
at the end of it and we're gonna do that
with Earth X with earth X what we're
gonna do is we're gonna take all the
videos that we've done and combine them
into one great big huge video and then
you just sort of throw it out there a
lot of you guys really seem to enjoy
that like a lot of you guys really seem
to just kind of put like this you know
two hour-long video on in the background
and then just let it play while you're
studying or cleaning your house or
whatever the case may be so we're gonna
do that with Earth X and we'll probably
do that with like the big stories going
forward with like the big story arcs you
know the the YouTube equivalent of trade
paperbacks so to speak anyway guys we're
gonna bring this to an end and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]